hello rejects nation I'm Greg Alba who
are you I'm Renee Ariel Renee Ariel's
rejoining me on the real rejects today
Renee you said you like dogs right of
course I like that if you didn't like
dogs a monster monster that's the answer
so one of our reward tiers on our
patreon page one of our top reward tiers
is whatever video you request whether it
be a discussion or reaction we must
definitely do put up on youtubes and
today comes from a guy named Eric
horseman okay and he has this video that
I haven't seen obviously something about
a dog it's called can you see the pain
in her eyes
oh no I admit I was scared on this
rescue that's the name of this video I
see something about a fundraiser over
here so Renee's gonna donate all her
money oh my god is this happy one of
those videos it's gonna scar me and make
me adopt all the dogs hey I hope so cuz
then you would get a much bigger
following if you do that that would be
awesome really quick before we go into
this Renee has landed a new gig over
with what's it called I forgot all that
they have specific names of the things
you said pop culture network called
the trendy we're on YouTube I'll be
posting videos all the time so watch it
watch it guys she's great she's a good
personality and if you want to see more
of her you can go check her out on
Instagram and Twitter but more
importantly watch her new show and
follow me on instagram at Renee oreal do
it all yeah headphones Renee all right
I'm scared I hope we end up in tears and
your makeups ruined god I hope so
Oh No zel a California oh my god oh my
god
if it's dead I'm leaving I'm not filming
anymore
he's a dead
[Applause]
looks like my backyard there you are
we're just talking to a dead dog I'm
sorry did you survive
[Music]
God is intense ass music she's so cute
oh that's good it's good
take it humans alike it's like a
jump-scare video I can see that go yeah
that's very very
it's like superhero music
oh good girl
the gentles okay
but gentlemen
I think so that joke I don't know how
you could be gentle with that yeah I'm
scared I feel like that would hurt the
dog that's what I like that they added
gentle where the dogs had freaked out
come on she's like I know I do she's so
cute she's gonna freak out I'm really
nervous
just do it does not look gentle
[Music]
why is she chilling Yara after she after
he plays the leash then he named her you
know you are yo okay get them when
they're starving yeah amazing serious
how you went over humans do ya don't
like dating advice yeah this is how I
got Renee to come on the channel
off-ramp
oh hey the gentle snare works Oh
broke my leg oh god oh god I'm really
weird with injuries oh my god no it's a
perfectly compassionate reaction to have
oh carrier have this dog survive pick
her up that's got dangerous to pick her
up huh
oh my god oh my god please tell me she
keeps her poor baby bring in all the
feels oh my god oh my god that's really
in jets really bad that's really bad
dude who is this guy so no knew I
couldn't trust you come on look no no no
no no no stop stop stop stop stop it I
think you're showing it along the
challenge you know knock it off knock it
off knock it off no no please please
please please please just say please Oh
[Music]
someone's gets you in water
we have to watch him catch Yara I have
the saddest nipple shows right now oh my
god this is just the beginning
wow this guy has so no it's not
happening so let's I mean I would
definitely have to save the dog but like
I wouldn't I used to me I would have had
to find a way to get her on my car I
wouldn't just test her on the side of
the road my gentle what a snare he's
trying to save her man but you're okay
you are a good girl good girl
Oh God why did he show every you know
what I mean like what movies would have
skipped in it sir well this is real life
Renee this is how tough it is oh man
he's really doing a great job at
building trust
and then I saw her last Schultz two
snares huh
very impressive gentlemen soap
again
man the music has really changed it
sounds like this time things are going
to work out yeah yeah the music music
telling me how to feel you have to pick
her up
why are you so stubborn I mean I think
the dog come on Yara he has to get the
art to event
yeah oh she's cooperating never mind
Loretta had to show up Loretta that's my
old car it's it actually you are you
yeah I really wanted to impress you
today okay so I'm gonna have you take
one bit and then we're gonna just gonna
be in opposite sides okay
[Music]
even here
all right there we go okay who are these
guys just like a rescue team oh my god
it's a trap out
they're in the trap get her in the trap
please I can't I can't ever walk with a
broken leg anymore okay
I know it is pretty painful to watch
good girl
poor doggy Oh yar you're my new favorite
doggy
I don't know what I would have done
without you thank you yeah we don't eat
that waited girl go Loretta grab us
there
so trying the RDA
yeah of course
oh wow River this is a full-on length
we're gonna watch long and respect to
you guys I don't know the guys name but
damn respect level of work you guys put
in
[Music]
don't worry alright you gotta feel a lot
better oh no I was laughing leg was
crushed
[Music]
she's so cute this is gonna make me cry
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
if she finds a home oh she found uh-oh
this is to a doctor
Oh to a doctor gonna have to adopt this
adopt adopt yarder man oh my god
look at her she's learning to trust
humans
[Music]
[Music]
Oh your gray aura oh look how happy she
is
[Music]
[Music]
Wow we'll never know Yara's story before
Wow all right I'll donate something yes
seriously I'm about to send my mom that
length we're gonna have a new Wow they
have raised a hundred sixty-eight
thousand dollars well one dollar more
coming your way at a Greg's bank account
okay wow that was beautiful
okay I'll donate 20 bucks hold on
[Laughter]
I can't screen record this to show you
girls my credit card number will be on
this $20 take it Wow Wow
I don't see that number going up it's
exactly the same right okay Wow Renee I
cannot pay you to come on the channel
today it went to Yara that's fine I
understand and I'm happy that the money
went good good give me five bucks that
was heartbreaking man that was very
moving
could they have edited it a little bit
to not make us suffer as much yes but I
think like it watching her that's like
when you just watch someone in pain
whether it be an animal or a person
that's so hard like having to watch Yara
try walking twice both times they did
not edit at all I mean I guess it works
no yeah I mean I really appreciate it
that they actually didn't really cut it
up at all in terms of their editing
because you really get the intimate
details of aid of course of a Yara's
struggle yeah and then of course how
difficult it is for what these but these
humans that these guys have to do to
just to help take care of a dog it's
like you know what dogs they're so you
would naturally associate that they just
love humans so much but every once in a
while there's a stray dog who's just so
traumatized that it won't want anything
to do with a human being but you see
that
core like by the time you get to the end
of this video that underneath all that
like trauma and fear and want to just
love and acceptance and to belong to
have a family yeah I think it said in
the end you know after all its suffering
yes sure was like a character beautiful
it was so sweet I mean how long were we
watching let's see when it when she
actually okay so the full capturing is
about ten minutes of the video yeah and
you're just watching this dog feels so
much pain these people are well the guy
that we don't know his name he's getting
he's so patient I can't say he's getting
frustrated like he's so calm so patient
clearly he's done this a million times
but oh my gosh what I just love that
she's so happy at the end I just hope
someone adopts her and then makes a
video I want her to have a vlog I mean
this video this video is from September
8th of last year so I feel like someone
by now would have adopted her she should
have an update like did it have anything
in the in the bio no literally nothing
like did Gaara get a home or not I don't
because she's about to get a home or a
yar I just earned one hundred sixty
eight thousand dollars is what I'm
talking about my goddamn with her leg
that did look so bad so bad and I'm so I
can't handle injuries like when it comes
to eyes or things being completely like
out of shape like and when I saw her
trying to walk on it like I could it
physically hurt me to watch her oh god I
feel like you suffer just as much nearly
as much as the dog watches but you know
what I knew for instance when you watch
someone getting her and you know any
video you're like oh god I feel that
even though you obviously didn't
watching anything with animals like I
get my heart can't handle it it's so
hard for me and I just want to adopt all
of them what's the legal amount of
animals you can have in God like there's
a limit I have some really close friends
who have greatly broken that I I'm not
gonna say their names that they have way
too many animals that they're watching
they know exactly who I'm talking about
a legal limit it's crazy I didn't know
that as a kid kind of weird right yeah
it's weird do you think you can have as
many animals as you want but that is not
the case
I mean hey hope for paws you've earned
yourself a subscription here they're
doing well maybe you should quit your
new job go find some dogs out in LA who
needs some help there's a lot of stray
animals out in the state I never see
dogs I've seen a couple are usually cats
of course yeah oh I see cats and like
that's a lost cause like I can't always
like gone every two seconds when I lived
back east though in like the wilderness
if you will like there was stray cats
and it was a way easier to catch them
but was like the cars all around and
then to go from building a building it's
very hard to get them my girlfriend
Olivia heard her cat went missing she
was watching this you'd be bawling her
eyes out okay he's still missing
no went missing but she's a she was a
trooper Amanda's story is is crazy
something went wrong on her cat ran
outside and she loves her accounts like
her the herd cats behave like dogs Tara
oh say would my god
we'll see so when her cat went missing
she spent morning noon and night never
slept just walking the streets walking
the streets for yeah we did that too
then eventually she found her cat on a
site that was posted at some rescue that
was like miles and miles and miles away
and this cat was put in the not friendly
zone but once she showed up the cat just
went right up to her and she was bawling
and everything so something like this
would just make it like she's a huge
animal lover and she would be these
people basically my gosh that's so funny
though that the cat was like not friends
yeah okay well guys you should go check
out this channel Erik horseman thanks
for requesting this Eric horseman is a
hardcore vegan so he loves loves animals
appreciate you spreading the message
like this buddy this is an important
video for people to check out and your
patron pledge a good amount of it has
just gone to them so thank you
I'm not losing a penny here by
contributing I just you know I got a
humble myself yes yes I can't make it
seem like oh look at me 20 bucks
Wow I'm so kind anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
notification bells because subscribe
buttons apparently don't do anything
Renae already I'll follow her on out of
the L R yeah I'm on the first one I ever
do that
the little lobster guy whatever his name
is
yeah she's on Instagram and Twitter and
check her out on out what does it called
the taco
that's her nd but Jimmy talk okay yeah
the trendy then yeah we'll see you sir